there's a great book there's two books
that I would recommend to people one is
by Steven Pressfield it's called the war
of art it's one of the greatest books
I've ever it helped change my life the
war of art
I love with his name Steven do you guys
know the book the war art is a Steve
Pressfield right okay I do love the war
of art that's the one book that I love
the war of art it's a play on the art of
war the war garden by Steven Pressfield
it's it's a book it's not a book on
screenwriting it's a book on getting
things done yeah I love the book the war
of art by Steven Pressfield that that
has a great prescription for getting
through writer's block and you know you
can sort of pull from that to apply to
any sort of challenge that you're
meeting along the production phase and
his advice I think you know the bottom
line is in order to beat writer's block
you simply have to continue writing you
know and you write each and every day
and the only way around it is to go
through it do the work as in sit down
and physically do the work and then the
rest of the book kind of talks about
fears and how to get past that but
through the lens of if you just do the
work your fears will go away
gnarly shrink but just true I mean you
know doing something builds confidence
and confidence builds ambition and it's
a pamphlet it's a very light piece you
could read it while you're waiting for
the light to change but it's brilliant
it is brilliant and what Pressfield
what he calls it as resistance that
there's this resistance sitting there
and you just have to face it you have to
do it and you have to stop trying to
like it
I don't uh subscribe to screenwriting
gurus because most of them have not
written great screenplays I do I do love
the war of art that's the one book that
I love yeah because and I don't think
it's a coincidence that he's a good
screenwriter he's one of the few who is
a you know is really
written great things but to me it's it's
it's not about form and it's not about
teaching you how to do it it's really
more about inspiring you you know and
getting you unstuck and I think that
that book has been super helpful to me
he's gone over the notes he's thought
everything through and he's about to
start the actual rewrite and he's just
miserable contemplating actually getting
into the rewrite and I said to him I'm
glad to hear it
you why am I glad to hear that he's
miserable because he's it tells me that
he's having the experiences that a real
writer would have only an amateur
Pressfield would would put it this way
only an amateur would imagine that would
say that she or he can't wait to get
into the rewrite is delighted
contemplating getting up in the morning
and working on that script the contrary
is the case dreading it
it's definitely if you're in any kind of
creative field and if you're stuck even
if you're not stuck and if you're just
starting out it's definitely it would
probably be more beneficial to you than
the standard screenwriting screening
book that's gonna tell you how to do
screenwriting but not really tell you
how to be creative which is like a big
thing you know there's all these books
and stuff fun on how to how to manually
do screenwriting how to do break down
this movie into three - structure how do
you write a three-act structure movie
how do you do the hero's journey there's
there's very little on how you
physically do it there's very little to
me this is obviously very personal
opinion the two most important parts of
filmmaking are creativity and
originality and there's very little
books on that there's you know there's
kind of books in the art vein of oh how
you be original but there's very little
and filmmaking on that and that's what
we admire in filmmaking it's it's you
know there's great movies that are 3x
structure all the movies that nobody
really likes and then there's there's
things you know that like beasts of the
southern wild something that's very
original
you know that's what people respond to
so it's kind of odd that there's so many
books on this one subject and then and
so little on something that matters so
much to me it's a personal opinion about
filmmaking the real writers hate to
write all writers with serious writers
they don't like to write
we love having written but actually
writing is always painful isn't good
enough
I thought yesterday when it was about
rereading it and it's not as good so and
I'm very very frustrating do I dare show
this to anybody how can I expect people
to in exchange for this give me money so
I can put out
you know author Don John my children's
teeth and so on this guy said to me it
was such a liberation to read for him to
read that that alright ok to write to
discover that he's not the the only one
who doesn't leap from his bed in the
morning you know with bells on eager
beyond description to get into his
writing no he we all want to put it off
delay it defer it it's that way for
everybody
you